I am detective Bob watts with Newport
Beach Police Department I conducted an
investigation involving Christopher
Aragon he ran a credit card and identity
theft fraud ring the numbers were stolen
off the internet the original cardholder
at the time when they were stolen did
not know that they often discovered that
they were the victims of credit card
theft upon receiving their statements
are going online one of the steps
involved to make any credit card is
obviously you're going to need the image
that appears on the card itself
they have different pictures to them
whether it be a mare Express or a Visa
Mastercard Discover but first the first
thing is to get the image of both the
front side of the card and the back side
of the card they then need to be pin it
printed onto the white plastic these
credit card printers are loaded up with
with the plastic they then go through
and has the three different primary
colors that combine to make your ending
image now these printers are extremely
expensive and can exceed usually ten
thousand dollars but they give a
finished look to the credit card because
instead of using say a laminate we would
peel away or not look as professional
this prints the ink directly right onto
the plastic white plastic itself here's
our basically a sheet of the Holograms
these Holograms obviously need to get
pressed onto the card and they're done
with this device over here
[Music]
this machine here has a two-part process
to it it's responsible for embossing the
credit cards and then placing the foil
tipping onto the numbers itself the
credit card starting here
they then run through the lower portion
of the machine underneath the print
wheel where the numbers are embossed
when I say embossed this is what I refer
to these silver numbers on the credit
card this here is a print wheel and it
contains all the different characters of
the alphabet and in numbers and then
usually some special characters then
they move over to the next stage where
the numbers are then tipped with these
silver highlights this here is the
tipping process it has the foil paper
there and as the card passes through it
it takes the silver highlights of the
paper and places it onto the embossed
numbers on many of the credit cards that
they made they also included the
backlight security feature which
required a special link that was ordered
from China
this is a reader and a writer with this
attached to a computer the user again
just like before swipes the credit card
through and on the swipe on the next
wipe it prints the information onto the
magnetic stripe they also made a lot of
fake driver's licenses to go along with
these credit cards to give their credit
cards validity in this case that we have
our proven loss was over a million
dollars when somewhere in the 1.1
million dollar range and we didn't even
account for all of the loss once we kind
of reached over the million dollar mark
there was a lot more there's enough
people out there that know how to do
this that it's a serious problem
[Music]